Why didn't you kiss me yesterday? There
's no way that's the case with Eshino-san. I'm
sure it's Sasa2. Oh, I see.
[Music]
Actually, after I broke up with Shino-san, a lot of things happened, including
getting caught by Milica-san and that person again.  I
did a lot of things with Se-san, and I
called Se-san a lot of things just now.
What did you do with Muka-kun yesterday? What was that
[music]? I never thought we'd get away with it, so we
didn't kiss.
So, Shino-san.  What did you do?
[Music] Show me how you tied it together.
Well, what did you do besides tying it together? What did you do? Let me see what you did.
Come on, let me rest on your
lap and hold you like a princess.
So we just hugged each other.
Then we talked about everything,
watched the fireworks, and
had some really wonderful memories.
[Music]
Why do
you think
you're going to be bad?
Mr. Noshino
[Music]
Idiot